damos algo sobre el producto punto el
producto punto francamente de todas las
bueno de las dos maneras que existen
para multiplicar vectores creo que es la
más sencilla que hace el producto punto
primero que todo vamos a darle la
definición y después vamos a trabajar en
la intuición así que si yo tengo dos
vectores el vector a punto el vector b
eso es igual a la magnitud del vector a
la magnitud del vector
ar por la magnitud del vector b por el
coseno del ángulo entre ellos y de dónde
viene todo esto quizás te parezca un
poco raro aunque creo que con una
explicación visual tendrá un poco más de
sentido bueno entonces lo voy a dibujar
arbitrariamente que tengo mis spector es
el vector am y acá está el sector b en
color verde baja entonces bueno este es
el vector b y ahora voy
coseno o al menos bueno voy a dibujar el
ángulo entre ellos este de aquí este es
de está
bueno hay dos maneras de visualizar esto
voy a también a ponerle el nombre este
es a acá está el sector de hay dos
maneras de visualizar este producto como
bueno tú sabes la multiplicación es
asociativa tú puedes cambiar el orden
entonces lo podemos escribir como la
siguiente manera podemos escribirlo como
la magnitud del vector an por el coseno
de teta por el vector b que lo voy a
poner en verde para para separarlo por
la magnitud del vector de ahora viene
este punto no es el producto punto es
multiplicación normal así que si quieres
no lo escribas en cambio si ves el punto
entre dos vectores entonces hablamos del
producto punto entre vectores ahora con
este acomodo que es a coste no de teta
si yo aquí pongo una un ángulo recto si
yo pongo una línea perpendicular al
vector b y bueno mejor la bola voy a
dibujar la dibujo aquí está es
perpendicular el vector de ahora que es
coseno de teta
que es igual con seno de teta coser no
se trata de es igual a cateto adyacente
sobre hipotenusa cierto y bueno de hecho
si es eso ahora cuál es el cateto
adyacente en este triángulo que formamos
la hipotenusa es la magnitud de a así
que bueno lo voy a volver a escribir acá
abajo ok
el coseno de teta es decir que ese
ángulo ese ángulo es igual coseno de
teta es igual a cateto adyacente el cual
es como le llamamos le llamamos la
proyección del vector
en el vector b si tú alumbradas una
lámpara perpendicularmente a b si
hubiera una luz aquí que alumbra hacia
abajo en una manera recta entonces
hablamos de la proyección de a en el
vector b sí sí me explico o puedes
pensarlo como una como la parte de a que
va en la misma dirección debe así que
esta proyección así se le llama bueno al
menos como yo lo veo mi intuición de
ello es de una proyección es lo veo como
una sombra porque si tienes una luz que
apunta en ángulo recto tendrías la
sombra de ese vector sobre el otro
vector
así que bueno imagínatelo esta sombra la
puedes llamar la proyección de a en el
vector b
llamémosle a su vez y bueno estamos
tomando la magnitud la magnitud sería
cuánto de ese vector va en el vector b
como sombra sobre este que es el cateto
adyacente y todo esto es sobre la
hipotenusa lo cual es simplemente la
magnitud del vector a otra manera de
verlo sería multiplicar ambos lados por
la magnitud del vector
así que obtienes la proyección de a en b
lo cual es una manera elegante diría yo
una manera elegante de decir que la
parte de a que va en la misma dirección
del vector b es igual eso es igual a la
magnitud de a por el coste no de teta
que es exactamente lo que tenemos arriba
aquí arriba en la definición del
producto punto ahora otra manera de
visualizar el producto punto es
reemplazar este este término con la
magnitud de la proyección de a en b por
la magnitud de b
eso es bastante interesante me parece el
producto punto de dos vectores es
simplemente tomar un vector
y averiguar cuánto de ese vector qué
componente de su magnitud va en la misma
dirección del otro vector y
multiplicarlos ahora tal vez te
preguntes bueno para qué sirve esto
donde donde lo puedo aplicar muy buena
pregunta porque bueno el trabajo por
ejemplo cuando aprendemos trabajo en
física el trabajo es fuerza por
distancia y no es simplemente la fuerza
total por la distancia total no es la
fuerza que va en la misma dirección que
la distancia así que si yo tengo bueno
de hecho te recomiendo ver los vídeos de
física echarles un vistazo pero digamos
que yo tengo un objeto de 10 newtons que
está sentado sobre hielo así que no hay
x no hay fricción no no tenemos no hay
que preocuparnos por ahora por la
fricción en este ejemplo entonces dibujo
aquí el hielo en azul está frío y
resbaladizo y digamos que yo yo lo halo
entonces mi vector de fuerza va hacia
acá va en esta dirección
ese es mi vector fuerza
digamos que mi vector fuerza es no lo sé
digamos supongamos que es de de 100
newtons así que este es de 100 newtons
me estoy inventando el número realmente
de almas solamente para que funcione
fácil y digamos que lo halo lo resbaló
hacia la derecha así que mi vector
distancia es de supongamos que 100
metros 100 son 10 metros 10 metros
es mi vector distancia 10 metros
paralelo al suelo y el ángulo entre
ellos supongamos que es no sé supongamos
que de 60 o lo que es lo mismo y sobre 3
aunque mejor lo pongo con 60 grados ya
que es un poco más intuitivo ahora mi
pregunta es a esta distancia aquí es de
10 metros mi pregunta es que jalando
esta cuerda o lo que sea que estoy
hablando aquí en 60 grados con una
fuerza de 100 newtons y empujando esta
caja hacia la derecha en 10 metros
cuánto trabajo estoy haciendo trabajo es
fuerza por distancia pero no solamente
la fuerza
hablamos de la magnitud de la fuerza en
dirección de la distancia así que cuál
es la magnitud en la dirección de la
distancia sería la componente horizontal
de este vector fuerza entonces sería 100
newtons por coseno de 60 grados te dirá
cuánto de esos 100 newtons va hacia la
derecha otra manera puedes verlo como
este es el vector fuerza esté acá es el
vector distancia entonces puedes decir
que el trabajo total es igual al vector
fuerza punto el vector distancia estamos
usando producto punto y sabemos que por
definición es la magnitud del vector
efe el cual es 100 100 newtons así que
esto es igual a la magnitud del vector
efe que es 100 por la magnitud del
vector distancia el cual es 10 por el co
seno del ángulo entre ellos que es
coseno de 60 eso es igual a
el newton por metro por el coste no de
60 y cuantos el coche no de sesenta
cuanto s es raíz de tres sobre dos con
eso es si es que lo recuerdo
correctamente y creo que sí lo recordé
correctamente
entonces x raíz de tres sobre dos y muy
bien haciendo las cuentas aquí por lo
tanto esto es igual a 500 500 x raíz de
32 esa es la cantidad de trabajo
empleado pero lo importante quiere darse
cuenta que el producto punto sirve o se
puede aplicar para calcular trabajo para
calcular qué componente de que vector da
en la otra dirección de hecho también
puedes verlo como la magnitud de a por
la magnitud debe coseno de teta lo cual
es completamente válido entonces que es
b coseno de teta de hecho te invito a
que lo hagas b coseno de teta es la
magnitud del vector b que va en la
dirección del vector a no importando el
orden que tomes y bueno porque aquí no
es como en el producto cruz donde no es
igual tomar
a cruz ve que ave cruza en el producto
punto no importa el orden en el producto
cruz importa el orden entonces ve
costero de teta sería la magnitud del
vector b que va en la dirección del
vector
si dibujas una línea perpendicular aquí
entonces b coseno de teta sería este
vector que estoy dibujando este bueno es
la magnitud del vector b coseno de teta
entonces podrías decir cuánto del vector
b va en la misma dirección que el vector
a y luego multiplicas las dos magnitudes
o cuánto del vector a va en la misma
dirección del vector b y luego
multiplica las dos magnitudes ahora bien
yo creo que es buena hora para que
entendamos las diferencias entre el
producto punto y el producto cruz el
producto punto termina con un número
multiplica sus vectores y lo que
obtienes es un número terminas con una
cantidad de escalar como resultado y
quizás digas bueno porque eso es
interesante es bastante interesante
porque te indica cuánto cuánto estos
vectores se refuerzan están estás
tomando sus magnitudes que van en la
misma dirección
y las multiplicas mientras que el
producto cruz es casi lo opuesto porque
recuerda tomar sus componentes ortogonal
es cierto y la diferencia es el seno de
teta de hecho hecho de un vistazo a los
vídeos del producto cruise que hice haré
otro vídeo donde los voy a comparar pero
recuerda que ahí se multiplicaban las
magnitudes de los vectores que eran
perpendiculares es decir los vectores
que no van en la misma dirección los
vectores ortogonales y debes escoger una
dirección debes escoger una dirección
ortogonal a ambos vectores esa es la
razón principal por la cual la
orientación importa en la regla de la
mano derecha esa es la principal razón
porque estás escogiendo dos vectores
perpendiculares en tres dimensiones y
bueno voy a comparar después en otros
vídeos lo que es el producto cruz y el
producto punto así que nos vemos pronto